[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si je vous parle du paysan à quoi
pensez-vous
une personne en sabots chapeau de paille
avec avec une fourche ou quelqu'un d'un
peu bourru mais proche de la nature et
des animaux
pourquoi pas quand même si je vous
demande de réfléchir de façon un petit
peu plus contemporaine qu'est ce qui
vous vient d'être acteurs parfois
énormes des champs à perte de vue des
tonnes de nourriture de la chimie
peut-être ou des usines agroalimentaires
c'est probable néanmoins est ce que le
terme paysan est vraiment adapté dans ce
cas là pas sûr je m'appelle delphine et
avec mon mari un benoît nous sommes
paysan vigneron à bordeaux alors que
j'ai pas mis mes bottes un j'ai pas mis
mon bleu de travail et je suis
certainement pas venus en tracteurs
c'est un peu loin
pourtant mon quotidien est bien celui
d'une paysanne
je m'explique on va commencer par un
petit peu d'histoire
à l'origine le paysan c'était la
personne qui vivait à et de la campagne
c'était même plus une condition qu'un
véritable métier à proprement parler en
fait on ne choisissait pas d'être paysan
on essaie pesant tout simplement
et puis il ya eu des outils qui ont été
inventés pour labourer pour semer pour
moissonner et le paysan il est devenu un
cultivateur avec l'apparition de
l'agronomie
on a eu accès à des nouvelles
connaissances et des nouvelles
techniques et du coup le cultivateur il
est devenu un agriculteur alors c'est
une période qui est marqué par la
sélection des plantes et des animaux
la création de nouveaux métiers comme
des techniciens des conseillers
ou des commerciaux agricoles le
développement de la mécanisation bien
sûr et puis l'apparition de la
pétrochimie
alors vous savez ce sont tous les
herbicides fongicides insecticides ou
c'est tous ces produits qui se termine
par le suffixe ce side qui signifie tuer
alors bien sûr toutes ces avancées ces
évolutions
elle avait pour but de faciliter
l'activité agricole qui c'est vrai est
une activité difficile et on pensait qu
en sécurisant les récoltes et en
facilitant le travail de l'agriculteur
on allait lui permettre de vivre mieux
seulement voilà du paysan qui faisait
avec le vivant et bien on a glissé vers
l'agriculteur qui sélectionne donc qui
perd de la diversité et puis qui
utilisent des produits qui tuent et le
métier a continué à évoluer et d'une
activité pensée pour nourrir une
population locale on est passé à une
agriculture de marché en transformant
l'agriculteur en exploitant agricole et
même si l'évolution
elle a permis cette évolution a permis à
la france de devenir un leader en
production agricole et bien les
exploitants n'ayant plus besoin de
regarder les principes naturels
agronomique et environnementaux mais
elles ont tout simplement perdu des
connaissances de base et puis au fil du
temps il ya des difficultés qui ont
commencé à être observées baisse des
rendements mais augmentation des coûts
de production baisse de la fertilité des
sols qui peut aller jusqu'à la stérilité
on peut avoir pollution de l'eau
pollution de l'air développement de la
résistance aux maladies perte de
biodiversité
et puis et puis
j'ai un souffleur devant halak est ce
qu'il faut faire
est-ce qu'il faut miser une fois de plus
sur les biotechnologies pour qu'elle
tente d'isoler une super nouvelle
molécule ou est ce qui n'est pas plus
judicieux de réapprendre à fonctionner
avec la nature de l'art est observée
pour fonctionner avec elle et non contre
elle par concrètement on fait comment
avec mon mari nous avons grandi sur des
fermes en charente-maritime dans le sud
ouest de la france
et puis la vie nous a amené près de
bordeaux pour nous installer hors cadre
familial alors s'installer ça veut dire
démarrer son activité mais hors cadre
familial
ça signifie que nous n'avons pas hérité
l'activité de nos parents mais que nous
l'avons créée et puis nous avons planté
huit hectares de vignes alors ça
représente un terrain de 80 mille mètres
carrés quand même et même si ça reste
une petite surface pour la région
bordelaise
il a quand même fallu 48 mille plants de
vigne 48 mille trous 48000 piqué et 48
mille gestes de plantation pour faire
naître le vignoble du travail quand même
et puis benoît ayant grandi sur une
ferme en agriculture biologique
mais on a choisi ce même mode de
production qui est respectueux des
hommes de la nature de l'air de l'eau de
tout ce qui vit mais parce que forcément
il ya un mais la vigne c'est une
monoculture et les monocultures ne sont
pas des modèles de biodiversité
alors comment on fait pour replacer la
vie nos coeur d'un écosystème
par quoi on commence et puis surtout où
est ce qu'on cherche la formation la
chance c'est qu'il existe en france de
nombreuses associations pour la nature
et l'environnement avec des gens qui
sont passionnés et passionnants
et puis surtout qu'ils ont toutes les
connaissances et les compétences que
nous n'avons pas
et sur leurs conseils nous menons des
actions pour recréer les équilibres
environnementaux autour de la production
viticole
par exemple en plantant des haies et en
fait on protège la culture du froid ont
fourni de la nourriture et des abris aux
animaux et puis on attire tout un tas
d'insectes et puis si en plus on
introduit des arbres fruitiers et des
feuillus au coeur du vignoble et bien on
permet de casser les vents dominants et
là encore on attire toute une faune de
prédateurs qui vont réguler les
ravageurs en ajoutant des nichoirs
on attire les oiseaux qui sont de grands
insectivores et qui en chassant sur tout
le vignoble mais vont manger plein
d'insectes dont les ravageurs de la
vigne
et puis quand on aménage le vignoble
pour accueillir les chauves souris
on s'assure de leur présence sur tout le
domaine parce qu'il faut savoir que d'un
côté les vignerons sont embêtés par des
petites chenilles qui sont pendus dans
les baies de raisin par des papillons
nocturnes et puis de l'autre côté on a
des chauves-souris qui sont des petits
mammifères nocturnes et qui sont quand
même capable d'ingurgiter jusqu'à trois
mille insectes par nuit et par individu
au bout dé renom se voit compliqué de
comprendre qu'on a tout intérêt à
accueillir fassent le boulot à notre
place
et ça marche alors à tout cela
s'ajoutent les conseils d'entomologiste
qui sont des spécialistes des insectes
le recensement de serpents akita parce
que les serpents font partie des
écosystèmes il
on a eu le repérage d'orchidées sauvages
et de fleurs protégées parce que nous on
a toute une flore sauvage qui ressurgit
le fauchage tardif pour laisser les
plantes aller jusqu'à la fin de leur
cycle c'est à dire de venir à grain pour
pouvoir se ressemer naturellement la
création de zones humides donc on a
creusées des mares sur le vignoble
on a aussi le relâcher
deux hérissons qui sont des gros mangeur
d'escargots et de limaces t qui sont
trop mignons et puis on a aussi le
relâcher de chouettes chevêches alors
c'est le plus petit rapace de france la
chouette chevêche mais c'est un gros
mangeurs d'insectes et puis de petits
rongeurs parce qu'en campagne on a plein
de petits mulots et de petites
musaraigne vous savez les petites souris
les champs et du coup on est devenu
sujet pour deux études donc la première
concerne l'étude de l'impact de l'arbre
en milieu viticole et la deuxième vise à
suivre le comportement alimentaire des
chauves souris sur le sur le vignoble et
comme on a la chance de faire partie
d'une dynamique on apprend énormément
nous on s'est dit qu'à notre tour il
fallait transmettre donc nous
accueillons et nous témoignons
énormément sur le vignoble auprès de
nombreuses personnes notamment des
jeunes dont certains viennent en
chantier nature l'été et fabrique avec
nous les nichoirs à oiseaux les gîtes à
chaud sourit les hôtels insectes les
cabanes hérisson que nous installons sur
le vignoble ont quand même ça ça
commence à donner du sens au monde peso
femmes sont en fait on peut aller encore
plus loin
alors comment je viens de vous expliquer
comment créer un écosystème en
production agricole c'est à dire comment
créer une harmonie entre une culture et
son environnement son territoire mais ce
qu'il n'est pas possible de créer un
écosystème
au niveau du fonctionnement paysans
c'est à dire une harmonie entre les
hommes et leur façon de travailler entre
eux imaginez
imaginez un lieu où le vigneron et le
maraîcher travaillent main dans la main
partageant leurs matériels leurs terres
imaginez un lieu où le vigneron mais
partagent ses pompes et ses tuyaux de
vinification avec le brasseur imaginé un
lieu où le monte-charge il à servir le
mardi pour des palettes de 20 le
mercredi pour des cagettes de légumes
et puis le jeudi pour des caisses de
bière un lieu où les pommes de terre les
oignons et les les betteraves pouce au
milieu des rangs de vigne comme à
l'époque des gallo-romains un lieu où
les apps routier côtoient des pieds de
raisin important les bénéfices de
l'agroforesterie aux vignerons et puis
par leurs productions complétant lé
panier du maraîcher un lieu où les
végétaux ne sont plus concurrents mais
complémentaires
un lieu où les producteurs ne sont plus
seuls
mais les solidaires et où on partage les
conseils les connaissances les aides
techniques le même circuit commercial ou
du coup on propose des offres plus
complète plus attractif parce que penser
à plusieurs où on affronte ensemble les
situations d'urgence on se soutient
imaginez un lieu où tout devient
possible parce qu'on fait ensemble un
lion s'invente le coworking paysans
aient lieu qui créent de l'emploi local
qui initient des projets innovants a
lieu qui valorise l'économie circulaire
qui redynamise un territoire ait lieu
qui réfléchit à l'accueil du public y
compris en situation de handicap ou a
lieu qui où on peut venir en vacances
pour se ressourcer pour découvrir pour
comprendre où chacun a son rôle
le vigneron le maraîcher le brassard
mais aussi le promeneur le cueilleur
et où chacun peut agir à sa mesure en
faisant ou en investissant pour
permettre à d'autres de faire imaginer
un lieu un lieu de partage et d'humanité
et bien ce lieu est en train d'exister
actuellement et il s'appelle la possible
rit ça signifie le lieu de tous les
possibles et nous sommes déjà de
nombreux amis de la possible riz à
penser qu'une autre paysannerie est
possible bienveillante respectueuse
collaborative est heureuse et je vous
invite tous à y trouver votre place
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]